hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is cameras never seen and today
I am watching Cool Runnings
this came out on the Disney Channel I
believe in 1993 or was it just a Disney
movie I don't really know I could look
at it I was only 2 years old when this
came out I actually haven't even really
heard of this film before dad was like
have you seen Cool Runnings
what is that nope no it looks like it
wasn't an original Disney Channel movie
it looks like it was just like a main
theater release film it really seems
like I've got my lucky egg I'm not gonna
break because it's not hard boy I am
very excited to talk about Cool Runnings
let's do it
[Music]
okay I absolutely loved this movie it
started out and it looked like it was
gonna be a little dated and a little
cheesy and it totally was and it was
totally okay I think that they did a
really good job of storytelling a really
good job with the characters I really
loved the main four guys I was watching
it alone and throughout watching it I
would just say to myself like oh I'm
loving this this is how I always am I
haven't looked yet if it's real or not
like how well they got it right before
the videos up I will I'll do some some
fact-checking and we'll find out
together you all probably know already
the story is about a man who wants to
run track for the Olympics for Jamaica
and him and two others trip in the
finals to get into the Olympics and so
desperate to get into the Olympics they
start a bobsled of team John Candy plays
a bobsled coach who in his glory days
earned two gold medals himself for
bobsledding he just sits there and
drinks red stripes and bets on things
and plays pool in Jamaica sounds like a
dream life honestly but I think it
really works well he's excellent in it
the movie opens up on our lead training
for the race and I got my first like
chuckle of the film before the opening
credits stopped rolling so it was a good
omen starting out you see him running by
and one of the ladies in his town goes
handsome as a lion that one I could
watch that backside all day
looks like yeah nice she knows whoa
Sanka is great I think he was really
funny
I loved the Sanka are you dead yeah man
same somehow like I said him getting
into the Olympics for track gets ruined
but then he hears about John Candy's
character being there
and goes and tries to make something of
bobsledding I really enjoy that it's
based off of a true story and I want it
to be mostly true
I'm hoping it's mostly sure feel like
Disney is gonna crush my spirits when I
find out that it's not mostly true i
just continuously loved seika's
character and i loved when he found out
that bobsledding was in winter and he's
like as in ice
as in ice winter as in ice as in igloos
and Eskimos and penguins that kind of
ice as in ice that's was me when I got
to Chicago so yeah yes so the film has a
lot of montages there's the montage of
trying to get John Candy to coach them
there's a montage training them and then
there's a montage raising money and it's
very Disney montage here we go we got to
get to the actual race portion so let's
just get this stuff out of the way I
love that they keep so positive and
there's a lot of lessons being learned
throughout they only have five thousand
dollars for their sled somebody gets
them an old training sled and so they
get this piece of junk and the lead
character is still so optimistic it's
like it's beautiful and so excited just
to be there and so grateful and it's
just it's so endearing also some of the
lessons that they taught people were
making fun of them for their sled and
for their outfits and just for never
been being there and as for various
other things racist things and one of
them was like why and the tough booty
one was like well we're different people
always are afraid of different and it
was just a really quick thing they could
have really dove into that aspect of it
if that's what happened they could have
really go into that but it was just like
a we're also dealing with this crap I
feel like throw away like it's in there
a little bit it was I loved it I loved
it I think that the writing was
thoughtful and it's so cheesy and it
feels like a Disney film but it feel
I don't know genuine still there's also
a moment where you'll Brenner thinks
that he's gonna get out of Jamaica and
out of the town he's shaming all of them
and he's like I'm gonna live here and he
pulls out a picture of the Buckingham
Palace he doesn't know that it's the
Buckingham Palace and they're all like
the Queen lives there man like you're
not gonna live there and it really
breaks his spirit for a moment and then
junior comes over who you will has been
picking on the whole time in juniors
like no we need people like this man
find your castle and gives them to think
back and I was like crying if it is so
thoughtful and sweet and cute I just but
oh now we're lying dancing in a cowboy
bar
there's the Disney I know this happens
to turn into one of my favorite scenes
in the whole film though the Germans are
picking on them because Disney always
has to have a bad guy and in this film
it's the German team for some reason and
they're just super rude to them because
they're like the popular bobsled team
but juniors like very down on himself
and she's also facing like some things
with his father and your brother goes in
and he's like no man no you got a look
at yourself in the mirror and you gotta
say this back to yourself I see pride I
see power and I see a badass mother who
don't take crap from nobody yes I loved
this part and I also love when it comes
back into the end when the father comes
and confronts him and he finally stands
up for himself the friendship that they
develops like they were obviously gonna
be friends they're the bobsled team so
they start off as enemies they become
friends it's very Disney but it's just
it really made me happy really well then
we get a very Disney cowboy bar fight
another like it's just good feeling
after good feeling after good feeling
even in the end when it's not a good
feeling it's a great feeling they
qualify for the finals and then you see
the three different races and they do
terrible and then do great and then
they're doing really great and then
they're terrible $5,000 bobsled falls
apart and they pick it up and then carry
it across and it was so good I imagine
that part is real that's
spire the filmer said this Jamaican
bobsled team
unlikely makes it to the finals it's in
the Olympics their thing falls apart and
then they carry it across I imagine if
there's any truth to this it's that the
bad guys become respectful friends the
Germans and juniors fathers they're
wearing it you're making shirts cheering
them on and they make it to the finish
line John Candy feels a sense of pride
for having done something good
somehow redeeming himself for cheatin
all those years ago get wrapped up very
abruptly and it wrapped up super Disney
but I loved it it was so feel good that
I loved feel-good movies oh my I'm such
a sucker for feel-good films and this
was definitely one of them I didn't care
that it was dated I just I just loved
real lucky egg it's a feature Disney
film not much and it actually happens in
real life
oh no the team was recruited from the
Jamaican army they weren't tracked stars
oh the movie also depicts the Jamaican
bobsledders as outcasts but in real life
they were welcomed warmly at the 1988
Olympics well they didn't carry it feel
the rhythm feel the rhyme get on up it's
Bob so the time was made up that's
disappointing
you will relate so hard to the Calgary
Airport scene
yes Marissa you will find yourself far
more moved by the ending that you would
expect from a 90s comedy yes I wasn't
expecting to enjoy this as much a lot of
people said that it was gonna be dated
which it totally is but for some reason
it just struck a chord and I really
enjoyed it
I'm not smoking I'm breathing yup
Chicago winter just prepare for a lot of
Jamaican stereotypes and probably John
Candy's best dramatic works I don't know
what else I've seen John Candy and I
know that I have seen him in something
else but I don't know what it was and
then yes there were a lot of Jamaican
stereotypes
it was very Disney Jamaica
it wasn't like offend ticket Jamaica it
was very Disney Jamaica sure is it great
you'll want to do the non sarcastic slow
clap that people do at the end of
inspirational sports movies this slow
clapping this was so insane there's like
hundreds of people just going like this
very intensely into the camera and it's
a lot and I loved it I had a blast
watching this thank you so much for
watching this next week I'm coming at
you with an Austin Powers
so check out Tara's never seen next week
I'll see y'all then
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you